I've known Larry Arne for a quarter of a
century now I was I served on the board
of his Claremont Institute out in
California and about 20 years ago he
came to me and said this Hillsdale
College place has offered me its
presidency and using my wise counsel I
said don't do that I mean you're running
your own Institute here what you say
goes and you're gonna work with faculty
and administration and these wild kids
here you know happily he ignored my sage
advice and it's one of the best things
that ever happened to this institution
I do think that
I do think when the complete history of
Hillsdale is written one day I think the
years of Larry Ahrens tenure with the
leadership of bill broad back on the
board will be looked at as the golden
years of Hillsdale it has been a
privilege to be with him he's a great
man in large part because his partner is
a great woman the lovely penny
and yeah he's a great man but for Leslie
and me more importantly he's a great
friend
ladies gentlemen dr. Larry arm
[Applause]
good evening
I haven't partner with penny I'm the
junior partner Pat is one of my oldest
friends and he's so faithful and
consistent and calm and possessed of a
good judgment and I'm grateful to him
I think Victor and Mark and Molly who in
their each separate ways are forces of
nature and among the most important
people in the world
[Applause]
a single out Nancy Johnson to thank
who's the head of our capital campaign
where she was Nancy yeah stand up
I came in just about 20 years ago and
there were three people working in my
office when I'm Nancy and two of them
including Nancy fled in terror within
two months she went to a more sane place
working for John Savini but I've never
known her not to do a thing well nor for
that matter John Sweeney or rich pay way
who managed the construction of the
chapel and my colleagues I you know what
I think but I love you
I said that in part cuz I've been cranky
this afternoon because some of you
couldn't hear and I made the point to
somebody oh it was so wonderful and I
said you know in modern times we will
never get a better opportunity to
explain the meaning of Hillsdale College
then this morning and about 62% of the
people couldn't hear very well and you
know at Hillsdale College we're not
prisoner taking business you know we're
cocky right we think we're the best and
we think that's not good enough so I
apologize to you and if you want to hear
I also noticed a funny thing and that is
it was the people who said in the places
where they couldn't hear very well who
were the most complimentary about what I
had to say
what are we to make of that but you can
get a tape of that if you want to see it
and you know just as Thomas was there
and the choir was gorgeous and the
building is you know not bad
so the last time I talked about the past
what the college is for and that tonight
I'm gonna talk not too long about the
future it's easy to predict the future
in one way the college stands for some
things that it claims are eternal let's
say as long as nature last so is there a
time conceivable when we won't need to
have a good character what is a good
character it's where these strange
creatures right we have these bodies
they have these needs they heard and
they feel pleasure and the first two
primary virtues concerned dealing with
those you want to be a coward you want
to be a dissolute do you think you can
amount to anything at all if you're
either of those things or any of the
other moral virtues which lead up toward
justice so as long as there are people
they will need to be character and all
of these things by the way I'm gonna
comment it's shocking that we don't
teach these things because they are in
fact the most obvious things in the
world is there gonna be a time when we
don't need to learn what is the thing
about us we're the only ones right I
have a favorite translator although he's
idiosyncratic and the way he translates
the first sentence of Aristotle's method
metaphysics is the human soul stretches
itself out to know don't you see that in
yourselves constantly don't don't you
every day meet something that Aristotle
always calls an impasse and a pouria
when that is you see two things and they
don't make sense together and that is an
opportunity for thinking and it's how we
figure out the world and we love to do
that
indeed much of our sense of our value of
ourselves is that we can make some sense
of the world learning always freedom if
there's a choosing being if you know we
have the you you you've most of you saw
my dogs our dogs right actually there if
there's reincarnation and there isn't
then you want to come back as one of my
wife's dogs and you know the most
troublesome one is my dog but she takes
care of it it's the nature of our
marriage and they don't choose now they
select or opt all the time you know they
know when to bag and I indulge them but
you know we here's the thing about us we
can do a thing and commit ourselves to
action and then wonder for days or years
was it the right thing something stands
outside our actual actions and judges
whether they were right or not and given
the capacity for that then it's nature
we ought to get to exercise it we need
freedom and of course because we're made
to talk and therefore were made to live
together under law we need laws that
protect our freedom and as long as
they're people we're gonna need those
things
god
what do you want to know more than
anything what do you want to know you
have these moments I talked about it
today but none of you heard it
don't you have these moments when you're
taken quite away from yourself even in
the middle of urgent things that are
bothering you or your compelling you and
you stop and you go something occurs to
you right
something high something that calls like
the Chaffin do you see things and you
think some are better than others what
does it mean better can't that only be
judged in relation to something perfect
don't you want to complete the story
when you start making a hierarchy of
things which we can't stop doing you
know I happen to be a boy
and so we boys girls are better
civilized than we are in my experience
they we boys we like if their sports
teams right we want to know like who's
better the 1927 Yankees or the 1962
Green Bay Packers and they will never
meet of course you know but we just love
things like that right like us we want
to know what the best is and when we
rank things we find things in them that
seem more perfect than other things and
that means we're always trying to go up
those are the purposes of Hillsdale
College and the claim is that they're
eternal meaning at least as long as
there is their nature so we know is
there right by the way if they're wrong
these 175 years mean nothing whatsoever
if they're not true every one of them
today then they were never true if the
Declaration of Independence you know
John Dewey and Woodrow Wilson and those
guys they're always writing that it's
somewhat outmoded right and that but
they say really good for its time
and that's an impossible argument
because what it claims is that it's good
for beyond time and that means if it
isn't true now it wasn't true then and
if it was true then then it must be true
now and so the college actually exists
to invite us to face those facts and
that's eternal that can't change what
can change everything else
do you think that tyranny might be
coming I do I don't I'm not a conspiracy
theorist I think it's open look at it
right what where's it evident right I
just as Thomas was arrested by my claim
that and you know just as Thomas I can
just tell you something about him he's a
student he's just you know in colleges
see I late in my life I was 45 years old
or so I started working in a college I
didn't find it like the plague before
and it this happens to be a good one
right so I work here and liked it but
what do you learn right you learn that
it's in the student and people who are
students by nature they get better all
the time just as Thomas is like that and
that means you never say a thing around
him but he doesn't note it down and ask
you about it later and so today he's
asking me who is the student of Hegel
with whom John C Calhoun studied at Yale
College because I think and I'm not
speaking for him and I would not do that
because he's the greatest man I know and
greater than I I think it might mean
that he's connecting things the friends
of mine have connected for some time now
and that is this here right-wing
Confederacy and this here
modern left-wing progressivism they
might be a kin
or as Churchill point the point but the
point the Nazis in the Communists they
do differ just exactly as the North Pole
differs from the South look at him
they're the same well he wanted so I
have to go look all that up and prove it
you know and if I don't I'll be shamed
and
and but I I can cuz that you know just
in the last couple of years I verified
it cuz I heard it years ago and I
started saying it again everybody said
really that's what that's about
see and I can tell you in simple terms
what it's about we live in the age of
modern science and modern science is
different from ancient science science
is that Latin word this means to know
ancient science is just seen to behold
to love the things that are higher to do
it systematically true enough but if
your idea is rather I'm gonna study it
and test and show how to change
everything the way I place the bacon
says torturing nature that was born
even before German philosophy but in the
19th century these German philosophers
right they came to understand what they
regarded is a great opportunity and you
know philosophers are very wise people
more than we are and so it's one's
reluctant to talk about their errors and
yet there's no choice cuz you have to
choose between them they thought they
saw things that they thought might be
disastrous but really mostly was very
hopeful and that is everything is change
and we are all victims and shaped by
that change but now we know that we're
the first ones to know that and that
changes everything
now we become the masters of the process
of change we could become our own
creators and then at last we would be
free now the free definition freedom I
gave earlier is God gave us volition the
implication is we should use it and
that's very simple that's an argument in
Aristotle right do you ever see
sled dogs running isn't it a delightful
sight and they're made for that right
now
I mean imagine horses doing it they
wouldn't be very good at that the two
long-legged you know right and so
they're made for that and Aristotle says
well if you can see that and see they're
made for that can you see what a human
being is made for and we all know what
they're made for we see excellent one so
we all admire them almost all the same
by the way I mean leaving out of account
Bernie Sanders and see this idea that we
can remake everything because now we
know everything has changed and we are
dominated by the influences that come
through change what if we could control
all those influences do you begin to see
why the government would like to control
every single thing why it's of concern
to them what we say in this room tonight
why they're not impressed with the fact
that fools though we are we have the
right to say it they're thinking they
can't say that they can't say that see
we will stop that
that's the temper that grows up and it
came in to America as it came into
Germany before through some very elite
thinkers the best right and it came to
an America and it spread because it's a
very powerful argument it's easier to
see today because we live amidst the
bureaucratic age and we can see that
that's dangerous and arbitrary or the
week we hear can many people can't see
that but back then it was pure hope
right because we could set everything
right and even those great ones they
didn't think enough about the meaning of
that term right because if everything
has changed by what standard did you
know
think is right and what happened in the
country since that was born first of all
it is known nothing but progress
anywhere in the world
Reagan interrupted it a little bit in
this country for a while Trump is
fighting against it
you know maybe artfully maybe not you
know it depends on what you think about
that but they can't really be much doubt
but he's fighting it oh I have an email
today from the regulatory czar I get my
updates every day now and then he says
next Wednesday something's gonna happen
could I be in Washington so you guys are
all here I don't think about that but
tomorrow I'm gonna figure out if I can
go to Washington on Wednesday and I got
no idea what's gonna happen but whatever
it is I want to see it you should watch
the news remember little nerdy guy Paul
ray this has never been set back what's
it done just think of one thing right it
is the most important thing for the
long-term
although it's not the most important
thing on any given day think of
education you know how that's been
remade I mean it is complete and
thorough so you know John Dewey at
Columbia and and Woodrow Wilson
Princeton and a few other places like
that they start going from place to
place the place and they're there
they're there Apostleship their gospel
is we can set everything right
nothing should be in our way we can make
it all fine right never mind what the
word fine might be don't want to Matt
don't want to spend too much time on
that and then the next thing you know
it's spread everywhere and it remakes
the face of the modern University you
know that there used to not be
departments I see yeah cuz he's so tall
I see caught up over there right and I
saw wailing somewhere before
many years have we been talking about
how we could get rid of all the
departments at Hillsdale College and we
haven't got rid of them yet but core is
the big deal now see because why the
departments are places of specialized
knowledge for the remaking of society
and that's what John Dewey analysis in
the document that founded the Teachers
Union for colleges on whose blacklist we
are honored to be and that means that
there's an any common-sense way to think
about what's right and wrong there's
only testing and so one of the things
that when they departmentalized the
university one of the things they found
it was the education department and if
you think about that for a minute isn't
that odd that in an institution of
higher education there would be one
department called education it's
actually kind of stupid and but what do
they teach right we have an education
department here but we don't have an
education major and the reason is the
people in our department are really
smart
it's Copelan here tonight he's been
hanging around a lot I don't know he's
the chairman dan Copeland anyway
they they they don't study stuff anymore
they study how to deliver stuff
understanding that the stuff that's
delivered will be defined by some
central place and so teachers are now
delivery boys you know my father a high
school teacher in Arkansas Hillary
Clinton you know cuz there's a pattern
right bill gets like a governor the
biggest thing is education she gets
control of that same thing healthcare in
America and and he just just real about
that what are they doing right our
school where I've worked all my life
they think they can run it better in
Little Rock than we
right here and they never meet the
students right I used to hear that from
him and I would say Oh dad you're just
annoyed at them because they're the
local thing and they're typical of the
bad things they said no they're worse
than that you know my life is a process
of understanding my dad was right he's
right about that too
so now what is it now I think it was my
daughter Alice one of the daughters said
to me that they were watching a movie
with some friends and that some of the
people are not such good friends anyway
there was a dinner and the women got up
and retired to another room and some of
the girls thought that they were they
had rooms where they were incarcerated
except where the men left them out
that's what Victoria times were and I
said goodness gracious did they never
meet retrieve Jan Austen it wasn't like
that well they think it was like that
and they think that you know do you know
the New York Times thing that's going on
right now 69 project is that what it is
America was founded on the day that the
first slave ship arrived okay fine but
did it arrive in America because it must
have been earlier except actually it was
much later was the document that says
all men are created equal so they
control what we know and that's
comprehensive and it's everything else
too you never know when you'll hear from
them and you never know what they'll say
this kind of government has to be
hostile to anything that's independent
my son-in-law Dan sitting over there Dan
stand up
and where's my daughter's cuz she's off
somewhere else yeah yeah and you you saw
her did that you may wonder why she
married Dan
we don't know anyway was I was making
the argument and it you know did you
know that when some Churchill is a very
great man I mean really I'm be working
on Churchill I still do all the time
and well be in bed now beware pending I
will take our computers to bed it's not
an entirely Roman or unromantic thing we
have four children Ted I'll be working
away and I'll say to myself Winston
Churchill was a very great man and
she'll say you've said that dear it's
from him and from Aristotle but first
from Churchill I learned that
statesmanship is presented as the
guardianship of wisdom because you know
people who are wise they get that way
because they don't go about urgent
politics every day and yet they're not
necessarily practical people and
somebody is gonna is going to oppress
them unless somebody protects them
here's what's in Churchill talking about
Hitler about who those enemies are
venerable pastors upright magistrates
world class scientists and philosophers
independent minded
manly citizens frail poor old women of
unfashionable opinion are are invaded
bullied and brutalized by ghent gangs of
armed hooligans why would they do that
the answer is this passion for
controlling everything
well Brooke nothing independent it
thinks it claims it can perfect
everything
if only it can get the power to control
everything and since the scientific
experiment is the methodology it means
nothing can be outside that experiment I
teach a course here and we read to
toddler carryin novels there's about
seven of them that we read various times
right but if you read darkness at noon
in 1984 you see this beard of it and
most of these photography innopolis not
all I written by people who saw this
firsthand indeed were complicit in it
Georgia are well waited in the cell for
three nights in Spain for them to come
get him and shoot him and he was a
communist revolutionary in the Spanish
Civil War
Arthur Koestler was an important
darkness at noon he wrote Arthur
Kirchner was an important functionary of
the Communist Party in Hungary and he
too woke up in fear of his life and they
thought that said I'm thinking you know
really what have I done it's horrific
and it's driven made more horrific by
the fact that it's driven by something
good which is the wish to ameliorate the
difficulties of human life which turns
into the root the wish to eliminate them
all do you see what it's like to raise
young children in this age I mean young
children 18 to 21 year olds that's our
specialty they're really great they're
almost human
and they grew up in a world where they
you know at least in the public
discourse they haven't told anything
except that they can be whatever they
want to be and we don't get that much
because this is a really weird place and
it's hard to get into and the kids who
get in here have learned a lot about it
but once in a while they'll say well you
know I just want to become whatever I
can be and I always say good you should
be an aardvark or would you rather be a
human because we know what that's like
and we know what the good ones are like
we take that away from this is a massive
and dangerous force it may overcome us I
said two days ago I said you know this
is like the great crises the
Revolutionary War that was a fight about
who is entitled to govern which is a
fight always when it comes up about what
is the human being and the Civil War was
exactly the same thing isn't this just
like it is it is it true that each of us
in his common sense has a right to
govern his own life which is what God
gave him according to a moral and
rational sense that only we among
creatures have or is it true that only
people who are experts and scientists
can really pick our way there's this guy
named Douglas Jay and he made the
mistake in the first socialist
government in Britain which beat Winston
Churchill he made the mistake of saying
in church within the House of Commons
and Churchill's hearing he said mothers
don't always know what is best for their
children the gentlemen of Whitehall know
better Whitehall is the governing centre
and you know it was just such a mistake
to say that was in charge of the room
because Western Churchill has made him
famous to this day for saying that
you know that's the spirit though and so
my last point is what do we do about it
first of all it's overwhelming right
everybody everybody fancy everybody a
lead all these fancy graduate schools
and medical schools and law schools that
our kids go to everybody at those
schools disagrees with us sometimes I
think our kids our kids are admitted
because they're really smart and you
know they're impressive but sometimes I
think they're admitted because of
curiosity one young man who went to Yale
Law School clerked for Clarence Thomas
later a really super young man important
man now yeah he it wasn't it wasn't
really a slur but at Yale it was said to
him
you're just a yeah white boy from
Hillsdale College you're out of your
depth here now and and I I don't
actually mean to criticize the man this
young man later found out that this guy
was on the admissions commission
committee that led him in why he let a
man he was curious what kind of the
people are those people right and so now
we're studied like specimens so if
that's overwhelming how can we do
anything about it well I'll just tell
you briefly what we're gonna do
I mean God granting of course cuz you
know I want you to know a marvelous
things have happened here and we don't
know him we just got up every day and
thought we knew what to do and we just
got about it and we got about it
together every day day after day after
day and you know that's a pretty good
way to work but we're not deluded that
we're responsible for all this
but if great things have happened maybe
you should try to extend them we're
gonna do two things when is this little
place was its graduate schools you know
what's growing we're kind of frightened
by that it's gonna be the most intense
atmosphere of learning on the face of
the earth it's already like that you
know coming here that's like joining the
Marines say goodbye to your 3.92
high school grade point average this is
serious now you know I had a girl Steve
Smith is here tonight you might be Steve
Smith and I have an honor
we once gave an a-minus to a girl who
only got those two grades in her entire
life from kindergarten other than a's
and she cried in my office and she said
what can i do and i said we should
probably try to do better
and she was you know she was sobbing she
was later our valedictorian by the way
and she was sobbing and she says is
there any chance I can get an A and I
said no get over it that's the wrong
thing to think about right well the
point is that's the ticket you want to
help them you want to love them you want
to nurture them they gotta work
they must not pretend to achievements
that they have not made now when they
fall you got to help them up and they do
fall you know and they don't bring me in
when they fall because they're afraid I
might kick them but I won't right and
this has got to be tireless and
relentless and no compromises
and I will tell you everybody I work
with and everybody on the board that Pat
needs and Bill did breathe lead that's
what they think they don't expect just
quick
then what do we do cuz this can get
better than it is it's going to mean God
granting that's what I call the nuclear
reactor the general counsel Bob Norton
doesn't like me to say that it's going
to radiate the country because he thinks
there might be some liability in that I
will say instead that it's going to
inspire something in the country country
and the means are laid out now we have
founded more than 20 oh well in Primus
it was 900,000 when I came here it's
turned across 5.5 million
and let that stand for the long list of
incredibly stupid things that we do here
because that thing cost a fortune and
you get it right we don't ask for money
in that thing and people send it anyway
I don't get it it's really great and you
know how many people we talk to in a
typical month now 15 to 20 million
counting the radio all that and it means
the colleges have been famous can become
famous right which means it's dangerous
because bad people know who we are to
enemies I mean we're gonna keep that up
and grow more and then we always tried I
you know I figured this out a long time
ago because I have this weird history
never worked in nonprofits all my life
and I didn't it never intended to but I
did and I figured out something about
them the things that they make that's
the most difficult thing that they make
they don't actually give to the people
who provide the money it's a triangle so
General Motors that makes cars right
they sell it to a person and they use
the car and they give General Motors
money that's a fairly simple transaction
but you know I'm looking around for some
students here there are something here
somewhere maybe they've gone to bed and
probably not you know you don't know
them and we just lavish resources on
them and attention on them constantly
right you don't get to see that and yet
you're paying for it how do you make
that work well I decided a long time ago
you have to do what you do best
for everybody and so we have two things
that now reach very large audiences that
are like that well forget the events
like this you know somewhere between 15
and 20 thousand people a year come to
Hillsdale College events and we never
sell tickets that to is really stupid
but we have these 20-plus charter
schools now and you know that's just a
hell of a mess and Lord if Waylon and
Bill brought back haven't hired my
daughter to try to fix it it's uh you
know and she will and you know it's
great and their problems and we're gonna
sort the problems out and they're gonna
become I can tell you what they're gonna
do they're gonna become the greatest
collaborative effort for school reform
in the United States
they're just like everything else some
of the people who run them are superb
and some of them are not as superb some
of the teachers just not to cover off
the ball and others not it's gonna
become a great engine so that the best
ones help everybody else and if you
don't want to get help
arrivederci we have these online courses
and these two things are two huge
academic outreach programs and they're
both one run one run by children of mine
what I'm Katie but the other Kyle who as
I said the other day I've raised from
the pup he's a student at Hillsdale
College and you know he's awesome I mean
he's not here right and and so he's
almost finished as a PhD he didn't want
to get hit I made him do it
and what they're 2.2 million people
taking us but they're getting better all
the time they're gonna be an enormous
engine for teaching to millions more
than now so finally when they're
elaborated there'll be two things true
about it one is if you would like to get
a liberal education in the second best
way the best way in seminars with people
who really know and other people who are
giving their hearts to learning the
second the best way take these courses
and read these books and watch them over
and over and spit and make that the
activity of your life outside your work
you can get a little bit liberal
education that way and here it's free
and it's gonna cover everything and
there are millions doing it right and
there will be we pray million more but
then take all that stuff that we learn
in the Barney project and in K through
12 it's just like college there isn't
any reason not to have classrooms we can
afford it in fact we're wasting masses
did you know that more than half the
employees of the public schools are not
school teachers
which means half the budget shaved off
and goes somewhere else we can we cannot
just afford it we can double afford it
but if you're not going to do that
because the schools are so bad
homeschoolers and private schools in any
school that want everything we get great
in the barney project we're going to
digitize it and make videos about it and
put it online
[Applause]
we've come to think of the college is a
different kind of thing it's a
combination of two things that have not
been combined as far as we know one of
them is it it tends to be the best
college it's not gonna stop we get up in
the morning everyday saying not good
enough yet I wouldn't get better if you
didn't do that by the way but the second
thing is it's gonna be a means of
learning for millions and millions of
people and it's gonna radiate that
everywhere and I'll tell you whether
it's important there are two reasons one
of them is that's a very beautiful thing
and everybody should see a beautiful
thing because then they will know what
God is like also they will understand
their own freedom and why it is not to
be interrupted and the second reason is
because we live in an age of confusion
that has become dangerous threatening
tyranny the only thing ultimately that
can dispel it is understanding this
college was born 175 years ago to give
that understanding not just here even
back then wherever anybody wanted to
learn you and God have given us the
means to make that big and we're gonna
save the world thank you
[Applause]